joe biden is calling on the public to
stay away from inaugural events
a request he'd already made due to the
pandemic but one that's taken on added
emphasis
since the riot of january the 6th
nonetheless seats have been installed on
the west side of the capital where biden
will take the oath of office
at noon on january the 20th it's clear
that the president-elect felt it was
important
that the entire inauguration not be
virtual
i am not concerned about my safety
security or the inauguration
i am not concerned the american people
are going to stand up
and stand up now enough is enough
is enough but instead of some 200 000
tickets
just 1070 will be issued for members of
congress
and one guest along with vips that this
year will include
all living presidents except for 96 year
old jimmy carter
vice president mike pence says he will
attend donald trump says he will not
following the ceremony and a military
review biden will travel to arlington
national cemetery
with the former presidents to lay a
wreath at the tomb of the unknown
soldier
before being escorted to the white house
by a military guard
instead of the usual inaugural parade a
televised and live-streamed
virtual parade will be broadcast that
will be similar to this summer's virtual
democratic national convention featuring
diverse voices and musical performances
authorities say the security perimeter
in downtown dc
is larger than previous inaugurations
and will be in place for longer
far more national guard members have
been deployed and the national mall
where in the past the public has
gathered to watch proceedings on large
screens
will be closed dc's mayor has asked for
all permits for gatherings to be
declined
but inaugurations are traditionally
times for political protest
and it's clear that since police were
overrun by trump supporters on capitol
hill
authorities already have a different
posture towards demonstrations
this protest attracted barely 50 people
protesting against
the republicans who supported donald
trump and yet very very quickly
masses of police appeared followed by
the national guard not far behind
where was y'all at last week at least
some plans for protests by progressives
on inauguration day
intended to pressure joe biden to the
left have been cancelled
i would recommend for people generally
in this moment to let the armed
right-wing white supremacist actors
fight it out with the state
the state has created this problem the
state needs to deal with it
i'm not recommending personally that
anyone take to the streets
and in any way put themselves at risk
as for the future though nadine block
and others fear that even though
authorities
had existing laws and military equipment
to clamp down on the violent capitol
hill protesters
the result will be even more
restrictions and repression
of legal dissent against those in power
in the coming years
shia britancy al-jazeera washington